there's some people who have called the
videos click bait i mean how do you
respond how do you respond to that
they are click bait that's that's
essentially what they are to accept that
they're not because they deliver
on the promise of whatever i'm saying
but they don't do it in a way that hurts
people it kind of sounds to me
like you're reclaiming the word
clickbait i think so the other big
question who's on the other side of the
camera can you confirm that it's brendan
behind the camera
okay i need to keep some mystery to this
so that people keep clicking
christy carlson romano so nice to see
you how are you doing i'm doing good and
i'm having having a time having a good
time having an interesting time making
this video content recently so here's
why i don't talk to shia labeouf anymore
so here's how alcohol almost ruined my
life so this is how psychics conned me
out of 60 grand you were making these
like really fun and wild food videos and
you decided to kind of do like a drastic
rebrand on your youtube page walk me
through that moment where the light bulb
sort of went off and you were like i'm
gonna tackle these subjects that are not
necessarily easy or fun to talk about
but i feel like that's my calling
amazing so two things happened one was i
did an op-ed for teen vogue that was
more about
the struggle of sort of growing up in
public eye or just sort of
things that happen along the way and how
you can deal with them and turn out to
be a stronger person for all of that and
then i think i did recently i've been
experimenting on tick tock with certain
kinds of content i had done something
that was more of a mental health
check-in hey
big sis here
i just want you to know that you have
value
don't let yourself doubt overstay it's
welcome
no you're awesome okay and so i was like
wow this works this became viral we were
like let's do this let's lean into it
and this is how it's happened i for one
really enjoy this approach that you've
taken you chose to sort of do the whole
let's go on a walk with your big sis
christy and it's you out in the woods
where did that format come from it came
from the tick tock that i had done we
did this small version of what
had motion in it seemed more captivating
more authentic more like hey you're face
timing me
and i'm in the middle of my day but let
me take a moment out of my day and talk
to you well it's very relaxing i really
enjoy the nature and the calm
sounds in the background and i don't
know how much you keep up with what's
you know talked about on the internet
but a lot of people have questions
do you have a final destination or are
you just out in in the woods enjoying
the outdoors
yeah that's interesting final
destination you know who knows what the
christy walk and talks will end up and
there's a lot to talk about so i'm not
rushing these um in terms of how many
i'm going to be making in the future i
want to keep going until i feel like
i've addressed everything that i feel
like is interesting and can help people
um but overall
no i don't know
you're just enjoying a stroll outside
the other big question about the way
that you format your videos
who's on the other side of the camera
now i i read your piece in vanity fair
it was sort of like a wink wink uh we
have to believe that it's your your
producing partner aka your husband can
you can you confirm that it's brendan
behind the camera but i will not i will
not be i would i you know we make
certain oaths to people and i have made
an oath to my husband i would not
tell whether it was him or anything like
i can't say anything
okay
i need to i need to keep some mystery to
this so that people keep clicking you
know right right there has to be someone
behind that curtain in oz right i guess
so yeah there's a little bit of a little
bit of conspiracy in in a positive way
even if you can't confirm who's behind
the camera
can you tell me if this person is
walking backwards for the solid 10
minutes that your video is being filmed
what i can say is that it's very simple
and um you know we as a team however
that looks and i again don't want to say
everything we are moving in one
direction but i'm not allowed to say my
husband's in the other room he's like
you can't say it's a secret
i have to tell you
i've watched all your videos you know
you address childhood stardom um
alcoholism financial troubles the dark
side of the industry
is there any story that you have
i don't know maybe uh second thoughts
about or regrets about sharing
i i don't think i regret anything
because i'm very
hands-on with the development it's
enjoyable to get that stuff off my chest
and while i'm walking it's enjoyable and
it is cathartic for me to be talking
about it the recent video i did about a
psychic
uh that felt very vulnerable for me when
it went live this is like the biggest
mistake i've ever made financially i
managed to give this woman like a lot of
money from my account
because she told me that i needed to get
this big crystal i'm very hands-on with
the structure of the titles because i
know that they need to be sort of
interesting titles but i also want them
to
deliver in an honest way and so that's
why i think that's the heartbeat of
these of these vlogs is that i can live
with that being out there that is that
is my truth essentially
was there a video or a story that you
either really strongly considered not
doing or maybe you even considered
scrapping it after you did because you
just felt like this is too personal sure
absolutely um i've re-shot several of
these because the tone of them wasn't
right like i reshot the video about my
sobriety
because it was too uh chaotic and i was
like just not
able to think clearly and that's another
reason why i can't just be out and about
in public because i get very shy i trust
that's why they're not filmed at the
mall with a big crowd behind you yeah i
tried to do one in target i tried to do
my financial one my financial fluency
one of um
in target and
i was like really nervous uh so i
actually do get butterflies when it
comes to some of the filming which video
has been the hardest for you to do
because it was just challenging to
relive that that trauma and have to
retell it to your fans
911. uh the 911 one that i did was very
difficult how are we even supposed to
talk about anything as
this is happening like 40 blocks down we
were all just so terrified and in this
state of just disbelief it's been so
many years uh but i i i very rarely talk
about it in depth and in a way that i
think is going to be heard by many
people i was like crying when we were
filming it and stuff like that and
everyone was super supportive but i
haven't spoken about my 911 experience
since we did this one so we also did
that as a fundraiser so that it could
benefit
the victims of 9 11. i for one just
really want to applaud you and i thank
you because these are not fun and not
easy stories to tell but here you are
sitting with a smile um making the world
maybe a little lighter for for somebody
who comes after you which i think is
such a beautiful way to to pay it
forward is there a topic that is
completely off-limits you're not gonna
go there that's hard you know there are
a couple people that i would love to
share my experiences about um that i
probably won't just because it would
violate
my friendship with them or my potential
friendship with them like i think that
some people
don't want to be talked about uh and
some people don't mind it like when i
did the shy video in my heart i know
that he doesn't care
okay
everybody always asks me this question
if we're still in touch and we're still
friends to be honest i don't even really
know if we were ever really friends i
didn't get a response from him and i
don't think anne hathaway's gonna blink
once at a girl she met in an audition so
here's why i don't have anne hathaway's
career
but for me these were important moments
and if they were to watch the videos i'm
sure they would track that those moments
happened and they would know who i was
but
everybody has a different story to tell
it's not just going to be spilling the
tea all the time although i know that
that's why people seem to like the
videos
it's it's actually it's equal parts
spilling tea
and my personal experiences
i guess
mixed with this like mental health thing
so it's like it is there's a fine fine
line and a balance every every time i
open my mouth so when you mention people
like hillary duff you said you haven't
spoken with shia and hathaway um there's
been some other names that you've thrown
out do you uh approach them in advance
and give them a heads up hey i'm gonna
talk no
spacious they're like
they're like oh no
chrissy's coming for me
have you spoken with maybe hillary duff
or reconnected with anybody as a result
of all these videos
i haven't reconnected with hillary she's
a sweetheart she's busy so you don't
even know if they've seen these videos
don't think so i actually would i would
almost bet that maybe they haven't maybe
shia saw the shy video kasha is very
like in touch with
all the art that's out there and all the
performance stuff and all the things you
know and i'm sure his people are
probably on what's going on with him but
i can't say that anyone else has
you have to have seen by now how much
positive feedback you've gotten people
in the comments are just flooding you
with christy thank you your authenticity
shines through you've helped me through
a difficult time
what does it feel like to know that
you're really getting through to people
by just being your authentic self
it's rewarding and it's a lot more
rewarding than other content that i've
made
because while it's really great to be
able to be making you know pasta with
lalane
and helping people touch base with what
she's been up to
it's way more
uh authentic for me to be able to tell
people what's really going on in the
industry or
what's
what i've seen and what i've what i've
made peace with is there one story that
you're like i am so glad i shared that
because i really feel like i'm making a
difference here
not yet
not yet i'm humbled by a lot of these
experiences so sharing them is in and of
itself its own
meditation
but i think that
if i can achieve
that and try to be as selfless as i can
as i'm i'm really unpacking a lot of
these things then i'm then i'm going in
the right direction for sure 100
and then of course on the flip side you
know the internet is a wild place
there's there's criticism there's memes
there's some people who have called the
videos click bait i mean how do you
respond how do you respond to that
they are click bait that's that's
essentially what they are to accept that
they're not because they said they
deliver
on the promise of whatever i'm saying
but they don't do it in a way that hurts
people i do believe a lot a lot of these
people are trolls some of them are bots
um some of them just kind of
didn't really feel like watching a full
10 minute video and
to them i say you're not my demo
you're always thinking like a
businesswoman yeah you're not my demo i
mean
i think it's the best it's the best um
response to anybody nowadays you know
that's not my demo
this isn't for you you know click away
click away
yeah
yes
and it kind of sounds to me
like you're reclaiming the word
clickbait
sure i guess so i think so
my final question plans for the future
are you passionate about acting and
performing or are you really loving this
this lane that you're in right now where
you're a producer and a content creator
and a tick tock star
a tick tock star i don't even dance
right um sometimes but that's true
all the videos you nailed the trends
thank you
um i i am falling back in love with the
entertainment industry uh i think that
having
my own input and having sort of being
the master of my own
future is is really liberating and
whether that stays within
the content creation
or it expands into you know more highly
produced things
but having two young children makes it
very hard to be on set for 12 hours a
day so as much as i want to be a
powerhouse i kind of have to
be a powerhouse at home right now and
and this is affording me to be able to
still connect with my fans in a unique
way
you